welcome everyone to our Tuesday evening
class and I prepared this game to show
you the game Levon Aronian just played
recently but one week ago against
Alexander Greece shook there's a very
very important game not only this game
helped Aronian to tie for first in a
20-18 Sinquefield Cup tournament also
helped him with this win to qualify to
the London chess
classic Final Four basically it's a
Grunch ester final tournament so if he
had lost this game he might not have
qualified and so it was very very big
game so he played d4 and Greece shook
playing with the black pieces was in a
more difficult situation he had to play
for a win and how do you play for a win
against the 2800 opponent when you black
and against e4 against e4 okay you have
an obvious choice right when opponent
plays efore and you need to play for a
win what do you play I like the French
yes I play the French but to play for
winning last round not quite sure you
know so you played the Sicilian defense
okay so but against d4 what do you play
you know it's not easy maybe a Kings
Indian but still there are a lot of
lines where you know you struggle
equalizing so it's very very hard to
play for me so Christian plays d6 9b d7
and we see some kind of key five early
five set up going out of the theory so
I'll run play C for normalcy 693 F or
Knight h4 nigh goes on h4 in this
position there there are other
possibilities here as well to play 95 or
92 but he just played night h4 the idea
behind this move just to attack I mean
the knight was under attack so you move
away and now you threaten to take the
pawn and at some point you also have the
possibilities to play Knight f5 and keep
the knight on a very active square so
Britt should play d5 what else to do he
has to protect the pawns we play defy
strengthening the center castles Bishop
before this position has only been
played 7 times previously ok
so we are already in a pretty unfamiliar
situation and both players were spending
time at this moment guruship must have
spent at least already 20 minutes on a
clock and that was the critical part and
you see a lot of the erroneous decisions
based on this game was because Grichuk
was long time you know and you know and
that being long the clock was very very
costly for him
CD Aronian spent more than 30 minutes to
make this seemingly simple capture right
but it's not so easy because he's he's
planning to play this move f3 and this
is already a novelty novelty everybody
know what is novelty new completely new
move never been played before
that's your novelty f3 and what is the
other move that have been played before
what's the most natural move that jumps
at you here that you you want to play
here
Adie when the bishop is on before the
pawn is on d5 from the French defense
you should know this idea what would do
you play to attack yes Queen b3 of
course Queen b3 was played rigorously
okay putting pressure on the bishop
pouring pressure on d5 got it
all right f3 novelty played instantly by
our own Ian because he spent a lot of
time here okay Aronian spend more than
30 minutes to make this seemingly simple
capture okay
but thirty minutes were spent he was
calculating his further plan this was
the only time that he spent that much
time in the game and every novelty
Bishop takes in three incredibly Grichuk
spent 43 minutes before capturing the
night 43 minutes guys
you have an hour and 40 minutes for the
whole game and by this moment Grichuk
already spent nearly 30 minutes so
spending another 43 minutes was very
costly you know very costly in general
my experience has been you know if you
start spending more than 15 minutes on a
move you know you already know the move
that you're gonna play it so it's very
very rare occasions you spend more than
that much time because there is not so
much you can calculate because you don't
know what moves are only I'm gonna play
here you know you you the problem is the
e4 is hanging so you have to either
Castle he didn't want to cancel because
perhaps he didn't like this 'if I've in
between move Intermezzo capture and
Bishop g5 so this is just one of the
lines that could happen Knight f5 we
probably have to take raga 5 very
slightly better position for white ok
but that didn't happen again
decision that should have been made
maybe 10 minutes 15 minutes not 43
minutes because that's just too much
time for a capture like this because you
don't know what type of plan wife will
choose so it popped like you know very
you know it's not like it's a concrete
line 10 15 moves you're trying to
calculate so he castles Bishop a3 rook
e8 it's very very important for white to
get a knight on a fight because if you
let's say play one move one random move
of course
I'll ruin you're not gonna play the
Knight b6 and now black is better
because he's threatening to play 94-95
he's got Bishop f5 so so that's the idea
to remember okay 94 and Bishop Bishop is
controlling their fire squad
so that's the idea to remember so Rukia
9f5 of course a lot of players this
block would get scared immediately here
thinking all this night is coming here
but Grisha comes up with the right plan
here he played really well at this
moment he played quite well here so
let's see if you can play like Alexander
Greece shook Adi perfect die b6
attacking the knight so 96 comes in
that's a little bit of a problem here
what to do with the rook things are not
looking back clear but now what did good
should play here he spent some time but
he came up with a very strong idea in my
opinion you have two moves with the rook
d7 and not perfect because I can take on
c8 rook c8 okay one second you and if
you play rookie six it's not ideally
either you know like he can't probably
know he's kind of not well placed here
which page three ideas later on so what
did we should play Neil 94 by nil
interesting and logical play by the
choke as the knight is well placed on c4
he is happy to sacrifice the exchange
for the strong positional compensation
okay so strong positional compensation
here let me explain why if you take
takes now Bishop is hanging on a tree
you have to move back there are two
threads here capture and capture so he
has to go here pushy
locks in the bishop
b6
Bishop d7 despite being down a full
exchange black has a very strong
compensation due to very powerful and
untouchable night on c4 and a strong
wedge spawn on e3 everybody knows what
is a wedge pawn pawn on a third rank for
black or on a sixth rank for white that
is a wedge pawn guys you should remember
that or make a note if you don't know
that that's a pawn that is obstructing
upon its position so it's a very
powerful pawn here I like this for black
actually I quite like this there is no
way to remove the knight from c4 here
and you know position is probably
roughly equal here but I think easier to
play for black alright
so lemon took took only 494 Queen c2
putting pressure on e4 and now Queen d5
blockading it and now here we saw an
instant decision instantaneous decision
by Aronian he already Atlantis
anticipated this and he made his
decision that if this happened this is
how I'm going to approach this position
how did he do that how did he play this
out
the big game that helped him to tie for
first in this tournament what did he
play here again computer recommendation
is rook F 4 F 5 ro kf1 you know some
some play like that Bishop d7 but it's
it's gonna be very very hard to win you
know this position so draw is the most
likely most likely outcome would be a
draw
that's what he did he played here Luke
f7 look at that played instantly by
Aronian objectively this is not a good
decision okay but it was calculated risk
since Grif shook had about nine minutes
left for the next 22 moves by the time
he realized it's just just a time
calculated risk guys it's it's a moment
you don't play rook f7 I don't see how
he's gonna win this game black has a
very easy game Bishop f5 rookie 600k
eight bishop g6 you just sit like this
tight there's no way to break this
position yeah you have a nice bishop on
a tree just but it's kind of empty you
know it's just attacking the empty
diagonal there is nothing on that
diagonal I'm in a long run you might be
in danger because if you somehow
exchange life screw bishops light
squares are gonna be very weak
strategically this is good for black
actually this position so in long term
if you don't do anything immediately
this will actually it's if black plays
precisely he is almost winning here so
next few moves Bishop played perfectly
so he took of course and now very
important move is Bishop f5 you cannot
play King g8 because he takes advantage
of your background problems takes takes
we see the background issue that's the
problem of being undeveloped okay you
don't want to put the king on an e file
because you'll take and also if you put
on g6 again look at for something like
this runs into Okafor so Bishop a5 g4
again played quickly g6 very important
to keep the secure square on e4 okay
security Foursquare and now he didn't
take because if to capture after take
yeah this looks just fine for black
black would play rook e6
I made this and this look only six first
first idea would be to play rookie six
so here
rookie six put the rock on g8 and then
can't even walk with the King King 1887
and black will just be very very
comfortable so Quincy one plate and this
is where Bishop made a first mistake he
played a move King g7 since you know
that this that's the mistake
can you play this can you play this
position properly here and don't make
that mistake what's the best way to
continue here what is the best move here
the the point here is white wants to get
a queen on h6 but you you can you know
and the bishop is guarding this F fates
worse that's kind of important here
because you never have the sukkah fate
but what setup black should use here yes
Ashish yes the winning idea was rookie
six and now let me show you that what
would happen so Queen h6 King g8 there's
not much left to take Queen h5 and now
yeah you don't have rocker fate here
because the bishop is there but you just
have to play rook f6 it's possible this
should miss truck f6 and abandon this
position thinking that there is no way
to defend their five pawn but work f6 is
very strong we should see one because
bishop is not doing anything now black
wants to go King h8 and rook g8 this is
what black wants to do here something
like this
and then he'll just be winning so look a
faith completely winning position for
black as he has extra material and an
attack okay this could have allowed
Grisha to tie for first and possibly
qualify to the Grantchester finals in
London imagine Jess chess game could be
very cruel you know one moment one
mistake and from winning everything and
then finishing like in the middle of the
pack you know and not qualifying so this
is a big game it's worth a lot this game
sir yeah all you have to do just find
this next two moves and here as you can
see the attack is there's no attack
anymore here but we'll just go rook g6
next move and positionally he can even
sacrifice on g2 if needed and try to win
this but he didn't see that this is
where things started to go wrong hip
grip makes the first mistake he made
three mistakes here's the first mistake
first mistake by drift shock which was
the result of time trouble okay
because when in time trouble you start
imagining things a little bit you know
you start worried about things so this
was a problem because you don't want to
put a kink on a collar of the bishop and
you will see you'll make a similar
mistake like that later on so takes
takes Bishop b4 okay now it's the
important position here so if Greece
shock wasn't in a situation where he had
to play for a win right he might have
been able to just you know finish the
game with this move just take it takes
to the look this ends the game
immediately withdraw so check here so
the threat is rook g8 or Queen g8 just
once the Queen's come off the board
black woman so check and here you don't
have time to take on a5 because check
actually you have but it's to enjoy
check
Queeny for now look G to check is coming
rook e8 is coming so you have nothing
better than just to get the draw
it's likely Greece shook so this move
but knowing the tournament situation he
didn't go for it
so he took this way objectively this a
stronger move Queen g5 and a queen a
foreign now blocking is a little bit of
danger now so he played a strong h6 with
the idea of Queen g5 and also creating
an empty square for the King on h7 empty
square okay where you put your King on
so there's not much to do here Queen f6
just king h7 block is just winning and
black wants to play now Luke g8 King h7
so Queen c7 check and here it comes the
second mistake you have three options to
go here I want to give you the option
here which one is the best which one is
the second best and which one is the bad
move
Grichuk made a mistake and this mistake
was be surprising to me because it just
looked like pretty clear that the King
will be vulnerable there because of a
very common idea in this position in
this kind of positions so let's see here
the three options we have is one to
entry obviously rookie 727 Queen f7 so
Ashish your first move
yeah that's a bad move that's what he
did I did
second best move at the best move now my
method of elimination we arrived to the
best moment that is Neil correct okay
King h8 is bad because you put in the
King in a corner and on a dark square
that means this bishop is gonna come do
these six and then if I were gonna come
with a check key it would have been a
little bit better but the best is of
course can't you six no checks guys no
checks this is the safe square for the
King because there are no checks to the
King it's possible king of two he missed
okay with nothing else he could be
allowed with rook F a check and just
take take take trade rocks but no need
to look at this attacking the Queen if
rook you want check he can even just
play King h5 you yeah yeah this is
leverage risky but check King b3
ruk comes to the 6th ranked Bishop
before Rock g8 and Black has a big
advantage not quite winning but big
advantage okay we shook second mistake
which throws away the entire advantage
ok my common principle black should not
put his King on the same color as wise
bishop right because the bishop is gonna
come in of course level play we should
be six Rock g8 correct rook g6 correct
King g3 this was very well played by
level I'm putting the King on it is very
safe and now rook da double question
mark with this with Greece should having
less mint less than minute on on a clock
this was the last major blunder costing
him the game which move what is white
trying to do here actually if you allow
this move then you're in big trouble you
cannot allow this move to happen white
has like a quiet threat a silent threat
okay that you have to prevent here which
move I'm talking about here what's the
silent threat here Neil Rock f6 I take
take Queen f7 I'm not too worried about
rook f6 yeah this king of - King III was
very very very clever by Aronian you
know because his King was a weak as well
but he found this heavenly you know with
a king and it's all thanks to this again
it's possible to bail out with rook F a
check and take take and probably draw
King him Queen and game you know but
again bishop has trying to win so what's
the strong move that white is
threatening and the move that you need
to prevent yeah actually that if we're
pawn it's actually black wants to lose
that pass so you can put a look on a
file that pawn is more like abstract
silent threat caleb queenie seven guys
queenie seven queen comes here back
position I cannot move anything after
this Europe cannot go anywhere and then
he would just go h4 h5 and win the game
so the Simon move is queenie 7 that
cannot be you cannot allow that to
happen so the only move that holds the
position maybe even slightly worse still
is yes Neil rook e8 only move so they're
just couple of moves a for Queen e6
okay it's a little bit easier to play
it's a little bit easier to play for a
white here but should be close to a draw
okay but he played Queen d8 and that's a
double question Mac and now what's the
winning move that's it
winning move which Aronian easily found
blocked pieces are now completely
paralyzed nothing you cannot move you
know anything you move is gonna be worse
it's possible he missed this he thought
he had this maybe but he missed a
classical decoy idea which decoy I'm
talking about here should be more hands
well raise your hand first okay
what's the move perfect and then you
take that excellent so here we should
play b5 and now and now you need to push
the defender away how are you gonna push
the defender away addict correct Adi and
I Rock has to go back he couldn't leave
the chief out because roof g'wan was
just gonna be a checkmate okay he
couldn't quite leave that so he had to
go here and now that weaken his 6th rank
what are we going to do about a 6th rank
strong players what are we gonna do Neal
better yes
rook f6 pouring pressure now he takes
and he resigned basically because he
gets mated what's the move ID what Queen
has seven Queen is there my queen is
there now yeah she's cool yeah and he
resigned the incredible turnaround of
events yeah and aronia was rewarded for
his aggressive play and he tied for
first with this win and qualified to the
candidates tournament and rook g6 and
Queen g7 made okay so this was a very
interesting very interesting game with
lots of nuances okay
very difficult to play in time trouble I
can tell you in time trouble it's so
easy so easy to make a mistake
so easy to miss Queen d7 it seems like
for a moment you could just relax there
is no threat you can play cook tea but
Ruby a just loses the game you know he
it would have been it would have been
better off for him to even pass a move
here because Queen e7 you still have
Queen e6 you know but once you put it
there then it's it's just very difficult
because you go here and you cannot take
Winnie 6 anymore so that's the that was
the that was the problem here
and and just this idea it without h4 h5
it's not so clear if you have a concrete
plan Ino not so clear if you have a
concrete plan to to break here doesn't
look like there is something easy
then clean yourself mate okay very good
so again you can find this game Aronian
grease shook and one of the most
important lessons we learned is time
management everybody you know it's not a
good sign to spend 40 minutes on one
more 43 minutes 20 minutes okay
I mean 30 minutes so try to limit you
know 15 minutes unless it's like some
very very complicated position okay so
it's very important to make sure you
limit your thinking and manage your time
properly to avoid because here imagine
you're right here girl shook has a
winning position but no time and
sometimes time is more important yeah
because here if he had the time he could
have just played that called rookie six
and then just took f6 King h8 rook c8
okay alright so that's the game so let's
do a little over review of the game to
make sure you remember this game and go
ahead start first off a sheesh d4 Knight
f6 continue d6
what did he play here he didn't play c4
I think the g3 9 PT 7 continued he 5 C
693 he never took only five efore and
now where's the night going here a lot
of people wouldn't go to a - a lot of
people would go to g5 or D - no but H
hole is good because it has this F 5
squared potential this position played
only several times yeah CD I don't in
himself you know spend a lot of time
here but at least he had a concrete plan
he said ok CD CD I'm gonna play f3 I'm
from here on he tried to manage his
clock better f3 played instantly n again
n is for novelty new move that never
been played before
now 596 and here I think a very
important positional idea here how many
of you would have played this move I
feel like some of you or in a lot of
chess players here don't think too much
about that ball they would just try to
move them just try to improve the night
and try to move the rook first and do
but no that's not what he did
Knight see for activating the knight
attacking on a tree attacking the bishop
and again this would be a very strong
compensation this would be a very very
strong compensation okay
and the next move all right I want to
ask how many of you would have done this
in a real game what eating anybody well
looking for is the typical mode okay for
a thing is the computer move actually as
a computer move Ashish here
Bishop g6 and unfortunately I go Rocky
six okay yeah there is what are you
gonna do next tough
played instantly by Aronian eject
objectively this is a bad decision but
it was calculated risk all right
excellent great job guys
and again you can go over the Aronian
game again if you like it was very
interesting complicated game a big game
you know I picked that one because it
was the game that worth a lot it wasn't
just the any game they play they won
that game was the last round game it was
it was a huge huge game you know so we
saw that and then we did the study and
so thanks everybody for coming tonight
and hopefully see you all on Thursday
okay we have two lectures Thursday
evening all right
[Applause]
[Music]